hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ihr habt mir auf Instagram
lustige Sprachnachrichten von euren
Freunden zugeschickt da kamen teilweise
solche Längen an
38 Minuten allerdings wurden mir auch
eine Menge Sprachnachrichten geschickt
die nicht ein halbes Fußballspiel
angehen und da schauen wir heute mal
rein
[Musik]
wie
kann man zweimal innerhalb von zwei
Sekunden rülpsen ich kann gar nicht
rülpsen
drei Sprachnachrichten angeschaut
die erste ging knapp 40 Minuten in der
zweiten wurde zweimal innerhalb von zwei
Sekunden gerippt und in der dritten hat
sich jemand beim Scheißen aufgenommen
[Musik]
war Jägermeister 2 Rhabarber irgendwas
da ist tatsächlich gerade der Couchtisch
zersprungen
und das war der Schlafzimmerschrank
es ist wirklich wieder Qualität pur
heute hey du bist ja schon 18 kannst du
mir kippen holen bitte bitte
ich will überhaupt nicht sagen dass
unsere heutige Jugend völlig am Arsch
ist aber
ihr seid völlig am Arsch also klar so
als ich vor acht Jahren Abi gemacht habe
waren da auch Leute die mit 17 16 schon
geraucht haben und so aber die hat sich
an wie 120
junge
ekelhaft Durchfall
ich weiß nicht welche
ich weiß nicht genau welche Sprache sie
spricht ich denke mal Luxemburgisch oder
irgendwie sowas
Französisch holländisch deutsch
die packen einfach alle Sprachen der
umgrenzenden Länder in Mixer und
sprechen das aber gut ich glaube sie hat
auf jeden Fall Luxemburg gesprochen und
zwar kurz zu übersetzen sie war auf dem
Klo und während sie Durchfall hatte
musste sie zeitgleich auch noch kotzen
ihr seid echt dann Ekelhaftigkeit nicht
mehr Ekelhaftigkeit bin ich dumm das
Nomen ist einfach Ekel oder Sprachen
lernen Babbel
die
[Musik]
ins Mikrofon
wieso so ein langes Gesicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es ist
also ich meine wie kommst du auf die
Idee die zu denken brauche ich nicht
mehr so Sprachnachricht deine Freundin
auf und machen eine Ziege nach sorry
aber habt ihr alle nichts zu tun mit
eurer Zeit oh mein Gott kennst du das
wenn du also du hast so also wenn man
ja scheiße aber ich habe vergessen was
ich sagen wollte vergiss es
ich bin echt jede Woche kurz davor
und damit meine ich wirklich so ein zwei
Zentimeter Schritt davor
mein Kanal zu löschen
geil
ich
ja anders
Scheiße
[Musik]
YouTube-Kanal was los ist das für eine
Sprache Alter Halsschmerzen deswegen
normal diese Sprachnachricht ist von
einem Mädchen
die klingt so als hätte sie gerade
Albert Einstein gefressen
warum
ohne zusammen ich weiß nicht was
passiert ist einfach eine Person die
sich extrem erschrocken hat
warum schickst du mir sowas
ich
kann einfach diese Reaktion auf eure
Sprachnachricht nach jeder einzelne
Sprachnachricht jetzt mit mir jetzt die
genau
ja
wachsen Max maxen
ist mir egal deine Sprachnachricht
angehört und habe da so eine kleine
Fragestellung an dich
bist du dumm
nach Hause
[Musik]
wirklich immer wenn ich irgendwie so ein
Community related Video machen ne
bin ich so unfassbar froh dass ich mit
niemandem von euch befreundet bin aber
halt's Maul
halt's Maul Vater lädt um fünfte
Schlüssel auf der sitzt das Auto
Mann du sollst denken das ist die erste
Sprachnachricht die vernünftig ist denn
dazu kann ich auch was sagen es nervt
unfassbar wenn ein Navi die alle 200
Meter sagt was du machen musst melde
dich einen Kilometer bevor ich irgendwo
raus muss und dann vielleicht noch mal
so 200 Meter davor aber doch nicht
irgendwie ja jetzt hier drauf bleiben
natürlich wenn du nicht sagst dann
bleibe ich da drauf
Krampf rülpst oder dann komm zu euch
Kotze hoch
zu vermischt
die
musste also beim Zähne putzen rülpsen
und dann kam ein Stück Kotze und hat
sich mit der Zahnpasta also wirklich
99,9% von euch sollten wirklich mal
dringend zum Arzt gehen
zu Hause waren habe ich noch mal fett
gegen Auto gekotzt
[Musik]
macht euch einen Arzttermin wirklich
vertraut mir oder halt Psychiatrie oder
so
denke und was wir falsch gemacht haben
warte ich muss rülpsen
der war unnormal stabil hey wir müssen
heute Vollgas geben ne ich habe gerade
gedacht ich kotze gleich in Gang aber
dann habe ich aus Versehen Döner
gegessen und jetzt geht's
wie kann der Typ denn aus Versehen einen
Döner essen
bist du hingefallen hat's dann im Fall
den Mund auf und dann lag dann Döner den
du plötzlich im ganzen hier reingesteckt
hast oder was
wirklich Leute solche Videos ne das
machen wir nie wieder